for this week's classic interview I
cannot think of a better interview to go
to less than two weeks before the
presidential election then one of the
few interviews were the guest hung up on
me
this happened with the guy from gun gun
appreciation day this happened with a
couple of other people but the one that
stands out to me is my interview with
Dick Morris Dick Morris the former
Clinton confident and staffer who hates
the Clintons and Dick Morris really did
not like my line of questioning there is
a lot of baggage associated I think with
the line of questioning that I was using
most people thought Dick Morris was in
the wrong here although a few people as
with every time there's a hang-up most
people thought I was in the right a few
people thinking that Dick Morris was
absolutely right to hang up on me
because I was being disrespectful
you be the judge let's check out this
interview I'm joined today by Dick
Morris who is the co-author of power
grab Obama's dangerous plan for a
one-party nation along with co-author
and wife Eileen McGann dick it's really
great to have you on you know since I
was a kid essentially in the early 90s
I've been following you and your
political involvement and as a kid you
can imagine I was confused when I saw
you go from the supporter and strategist
of Bill Clinton to a guy who has become
very very critical of Democrats and
critical of President Obama so I'd love
just to kind of set the context for our
interview to go back growing up were you
a liberal or a conservative guy yeah I I
would say strong liberal growing up and
was very involved in the peace movement
and anti-nuclear war and all of that and
then Reagan became president and did
everything I didn't agree with he Star
Wars defense spending the build-up no
arms negotiations and Russia fell apart
and he achieved exactly what I wanted
which was to avert the threat of nuclear
war and I began to reconsider my
liberalism
say maybe you can achieve the objectives
he wanted to achieve and still want to
achieve better through conservative
means then through liberal means the
straight local path is as always the
right one and I've worked and for
example welfare reform we made people
work and have time limits on welfare and
we touched child poverty by a third
something that the Great Society was
never able to do uh the and what
happened professionally is that starting
in 77 I worked for only Democrats and my
first client was Bill Clinton when I
helped him get elected governor of
Arkansas right then starting in 1980 I
began to work for Republicans
- and got a bunch of them elected and
then in 1990 I became a full-time
Republican and except for Bill delay
grandfathered in and when Clinton lost
Congress of 94 he called me to come work
for him in part because I was a
Republican and because I knew what they
eat for breakfast and he felt that with
me he could work with them and get a lot
of stuff done and that's in fact how we
passed the balanced budget and welfare
reform and a whole lot of other really
good bills and did you take heat from
Republicans for working so closely with
Bill Clinton or did they see it as well
no we've got a guy on the inside no no I
was excommunicated nobody I couldn't
work as a consultant for the Republican
Party again but I knew that when I
accepted the gig with Clinton but looked
you know when the president calls you
and you've had a 30-year relationship
with them 20-year relationship and and
you can play the key role in his
presidency you do it and I gave him I'm
very proud of what we did there but then
after I left him I was free to speak in
my own name not in somebody else's and I
articulated the opinions that I'd come
to anyway during that period and I'll
say this to you
Bill Clinton right now would be a great
president he would not be like Obama he
wouldn't be like
and I think he'd be terrific do you
agree that it would probably be more
progressive than either of those two no
you don't think so less no Clinton
balanced the budget
Clinton made welfare recipients work in
order to get welfare Clinton increased
the defense spending Clinton didn't move
to take over education he deliberately
did not ratify the Kyoto Accord under
law climate change Clinton signed the
Defense of Marriage Act he's much huge
apart a moderate and only a liberal when
he has to be politically like he does
now because his wife wants to be
President as a Democrat Hillary on the
other hand is a liberal and a radical
when she can be and moderate only when
she has to be do you do you still have
any relationship at all with the
Clintons or did that end when you
resigned no it didn't well it ended a
few years after I resigned I was
involved with him for a couple of years
after that but Hillary sent me a nice
card announcing the birth of her
granddaughter but there was white powder
on the outside so I didn't open it so
I'd like to talk about my new book which
is called power grab
Obama's dangerous plan for one party
nation and the concept is that we all
say that Obama's goal is a socialized
medicine or to create a social democracy
like they have in Europe income
redistribution
fighting climate change those who are on
my view means to an end the end is a
permanent Democratic liberal majority in
the United States that always wins
elections and the Republicans never win
another election and everything he's
doing I think you started with
immigration he wants to create
Democratic Party demographics in the
United States and he can't to Congress
so he'll do it any way he possibly can
so let's stop there because I but I have
a question on that let me
just so we can take it piece by piece
much of the demographic shifts that
we're seeing towards what I agree with
you would be a more traditionally
democratic voting demographic makeup of
the country precedes president obama
significantly i mean when we talk about
the children from Central American
countries that are allowed to legally
stay that was a law that george w bush
signed in how is this so much about
obama well the bush signature that's
your your you're confusing it when bush
signed it it was about human trafficking
victims it was not about refugees the
law does not apply to refugees
consortium folks not refugees the types
that are coming in now illegal
immigrants are not covered by the bush
law the bush law only relates to the
victims of domestic of human trafficking
and that's what that law was about but
what obama is doing is he just announced
two days ago that he is going to give
those kids refugee status now there's no
war going on in central america there's
no disease their democracies there's no
repressive government there's no
religious persecution they're fleeing
crime and and poverty and he's go to the
UN and obama have agreed that they will
treat these folks as refugees which
means they can apply in their own
country and come here legally and become
citizens that it's his objective to get
them to vote democrat another good
example is on friday he announced that
illegal immigrants would be recruited
into the military right now only green
card holders and citizens can join the
military 5,000 legal immigrants join in
the military a year right okay issue
i have to take issue though something
you said was not accurate which is that
it's unheard of to grant refugee status
when the the origin country is not one
that is officially at war the US has
long history of doing this with
countries from every single continent
where there is no official war based on
the individual circumstances so it's
just flat-out inaccurate what you said
no that is not true we there are
instances frequent instances where an
individual gets refugee status or
political asylum based on his individual
situation right but to come but to grant
amnesty to might immigrants from a
country has only occurred in wartime for
your disease for example Iraq a hundred
thousand people Syria a hundred thousand
the Vietnamese boat people okay right
thing I understanding what we're getting
at but the thing is you're assuming that
all of these individuals are just being
allowed to stay without any
investigation whatsoever being done my
friends and the Border Patrol told me
very clearly that it's not just an open
door every case is is looked at
individually yeah but that's the ones
who are coming in be at the border
that's that's not going to happen in the
future they're going to be processed by
the UN as refugees in their home in
Central America but you're saying that's
the future that's that's not even
happening yet right your so you just
said Obama just ordered it listen we
don't have a lot of time what my book is
about it's the concept in it is that he
is trying to have a permanent majority
of people say that he screwed up the
economy when we look at a two hundred
and fifty percent return in stocks when
we look at unemployment and continuing
to decrease consumer confidence
continuing to increase it's a little bit
faster excuse me though dick it's a
little bit haphazard to say that the
economy has gotten worse it's gotten
drastically better no it happens the
stock market does is its own creature
fueled by federal currency printing when
you talk about what we saying about the
economy but after the stock market you
said something else yeah unemployment
unemployment is down to the point that
Romney promised he would get it down to
when Obama took office
they were 145 million Americans who were
employed now there are 125 million who
are employed quickly
the Hillary daily.com what is it is it a
Hillary Clinton it's mere sight my wife
is it's a website my wife is doing which
has all the information you'd ever want
to know about Hillary Clinton negative
largely although some neutrals some
positive I'm not surprised
anybody who wants to understand this
person needs to go to that website and
let me say that I know Hillary better
than almost anybody who's commenting on
her in the public sphere
including the spokesman and supporters
because they haven't worked with her for
more than twenty years in the kind of
clothes way that I have and but I
thought you said I thought you said it
had also been 20 years since you worked
with it I'm sorry what I thought you
said it had also been about 20 years
since you worked with her yeah that's
right oh so you haven't worked with her
for as long as all of those other people
okay well thanks very much nice
interview
all right apparently Dick Morris not
liking the simple pointing out that he
is criticizing those who comment on
Hillary for not having worked with her
for 20 years and he also hasn't worked
with her for 20 years I didn't think
that that was that angering of a
statement to make but apparently it was
- Dick Morris